1995.
HE CALLED ON REPUBLICANS TO
CAMPAIGN WITH OPTIMISM AND
ORGANIZATION.
REPUBLICANS BELIEVE THEY ARE IN
PRIME POSITION TO PICK UP A U.S.
SENATE SEAT IN INDIANA THIS
FALL, BUT THEY ARE TRYING TO
MAKE SURE THE PRIMARY CAMPAIGN
BRINGS OUT THE RIGHT CANDIDATE
TO TAKE ON INCUMBENT DEMOCRAT
JOE DONNELLY IN NOVEMBER.
CORRESPONDENT PETER DOOCY TELLS
US IT IS ALL ABOUT WHICH MAN IS
THE CLOSEST THING TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> TO SAVE A BLUE SEAT IN DEEP
RED INDIANA, DEMOCRATIC
SENATOR JOE DONNELLY IS
APPEALING TO VOTERS WHO WANT TO
MAKE AMERICA GREAT AGAIN,
SOMETIMES.
>> I VOTED WITH THE PRESIDENT
62% OF THE TIME, VOTED FOR
JUSTICE GORSUCH.
WE  WE HAVE WORKED TOGETHER AND
AUBREY WRIGHT ISSUES, VETERANS
ISSUES.
>> HE WAS A "NO" ON TAX REFORM
EVEN THOUGH HE WAS WARNED WHAT A
KNOW WHAT MEAN.
>> WE WILL COME HERE, CAMPAIGN
AGAINST HIM LIKE YOU WOULDN'T
KNOW.
>> THE PRESIDENT THAT THE SEAT
IS PRICELESS BECAUSE HE BEAT
CLEMSON BY 19 POINTS IN 2016
WITH THE STATE'S FORMER GOVERNOR
WITH THE STATE'S FORMER GOVERNOO
WITH THE STATE'S FORMER GOVERNO
WITH THE STATE'S FORMER GOVERNOH
WITH THE STATE'S FORMER GOVERNOE
WITH THE STATE'S FORMER GOVERNOT
WITH THE STATE'S FORMER GOVERNOC
WITH THE STATE'S FORMER GOVERNOA
WITH THE STATE'S FORMER GOVERNOD
BENEFITED FROM GLOWING
ENDORSEMENTS BY TWO OF THE
STATE'S MOST BELOVED COACHES,
BOBBY KNIGHT AND WHO HOLD.
ONE CONTENDER, CONGRESSMAN TODD,
SAYS HE HAS SUPPORTED THE
PRESIDENT LONGER THAN
CONGRESSMEN WHO LUC MESSER, WHO
ONCE SUGGESTED TRUMP COULD BE
REPLACED AS NOMINATE AT THE
CONVENTION.
>> IF HE DIDN'T BELIEVE IN HIM
DURING THE CAMPAIGN, HE'S NOT
GOING TO BELIEVE IN HIM NOW.
>> HE SAYS HIS FORMER WABASH
COLLEGE CLASSMATE IS THE WRONG
CHOICE.
>> WHERE AREA DIFFERENT KETTLE
OF FISH.
HE IS AN ESTABLISHMENT.
>> MESSER DISAGREES, ARGUING
THAT ROTIKA CAN BE THE GREATER
TRUMP ALLY BECAUSE HE VOTED
AGAINST THE BUDGET.
>> MY PARTNER TALKS TOUGH, SO
WHEN IT'S TIME TO SHOW COURAGE
AND VOTE FOR THE AGENDA, HE
VOTES NO.
>> A THIRD G.O.P. CHALLENGER,
BUSINESSMAN MIKE BRAUN, IS USING
CARDBOARD CUTOUTS TO HIGHLIGHT
SIMILARITIES BETWEEN ROTIKA AND
MESSER.
>> WHERE DO YOU THINK THEY LIVE?
>> WASHINGTON.
>> ONE OF THEM DOES.
>> MESSER'S WIFE AND KIDS LIVE
IN VIRGINIA AND THAT OF STATE
RESIDENCY RAISES QUESTION
SIMILAR TO THOSE THAT DOOMED
LONGTIME INCUMBENT
SENATOR RICHARD LUGAR AND THE
2012 PRIMARY.
>> I'VE GOT A HOME IN INDIANHEAD
THAT I'VE OWNED FOR 17 YEARS, MY
KIDS NEED A FULL-TIME FATHER BUT
IT WILL TELL YOU THIS, I WAS
HOLLYWOOD HOOSIERS ARE FOCUSED
ON.
>> WHICH EVER REPUBLICAN WINS
WILL FACE A RARE KIND OF
DEMOCRAT AND DONNELLY.
>> I'VE TRIED NOT TO SERVE AS
EITHER DEMOCRATIC OR REPUBLICAN,
BUT AS A HOOSIER.
>> I JUST SPOKE TO A STATE
G.O.P. OFFICIAL WHO TELLS ME
THAT DONNELLY IS VULNERABLE AND
IT'S NOT A CAKEWALK TO BEAT HIM.
BUT THEY ARE CONFIDENT THAT
WHOEVER WHO WINS, THEY WILL
BECOME THE NEXT SENATOR FROM
INDIANA AND THERE IS NO CONCERN
AT THE STATE LEVEL AT THIS POINT
ABOUT THE INFIGHTING.
INSTEAD, THE PARTY SEES IT AS A
WAY TO GET DAMAGING INFORMATION